When you look at public opinion,
one of the clearest markers of how
dramatically things have shifted as the
number of people who say that they know
an openly gay or lesbian person.
Uh,
back in 1985,
it was 24% of Americans who said they
knew,
uh,
open gay or lesbian person,
by last year that had shifted up to 88%.
And so,
um,
you know,
we actually dedicated the book,
it's a statistics book.
We dedicated the book to a,
an unknown number,
which is the number of people who have
had the courage to come out.
Um,
and that's an impossible number to
documenter or quantify,
but I think it is the starting point for
the revolutionary progress that has been
made.
Um,
you know,
Harvey Milk and other pioneers of gay
and Lesbian Liberation made that basic
point that coming out was a first step
towards greater equality because
visibility would lead straight Americans
to understand and accept and embrace and
an advocate for equality for lgbt folks.
And so this movement toward acceptance I
think is completely intertwined with the
growing visibility and the openness and
honesty that lgbt folks have embraced.
The,
I do think data collection and,
and uh,
the dissemination of,
of survey results and polls,
um,
is really important.
Um,
at the same time,
I think,
um,
you know,
if we're talking about what the single
most important factor might be in,
in terms of the revolution toward
greater equality for lgbt people,
um,
I think you,
you got to look at the media and the,
the idea that media portrayals have
shifted so dramatically.
Um,
that's one of my favorite chapters in
the book actually.
I'm the section on film and TV and other
forms of media,
um,
which when you look at early television
portrayals in the seventies and
eighties,
um,
there were occasional gay and lesbian
characters,
but generally the laughing stock of any
given show and the,
you know,
the very first gay couple,
um,
was on a norman lear a series called hot
l Baltimore about this hotel in
Baltimore.
Um,
that program wasn't even broadcast in
Baltimore and it was canceled after a
handful of episodes.
And it was proceeded by this warning,
um,
you know,
to,
to make sure parents didn't allow their
children to be corrupted by the,
uh,
morally questionable content.
And so you fast forward from that to
something like will and grace or the
ellen degeneres show where you have open
gay and lesbian characters.
I'm actually living their lives and
people can quibble.
Um,
and I think for good reason with some of
the portrayals.
But when you look at the overall trend,
just the very fact that mainstream
television and network television is
showing and embracing,
um,
healthy gay characters in committed
relationships and a,
a really,
uh,
positive light.
I do think that has been fundamental to
the changes we've seen.
And then I also think that the ongoing
collection of data through organizations
like Gallup and the Williams Institute,
um,
is,
is also fundamental in terms of
reminding people that there is this
trend towards greater acceptance.
And I think one,
you know,
that,
that growing acceptance as reflected by
the numbers leads people to be more open
with pollsters.
So that if the Gallup's numbers on,
you know,
should same sex activity be legal as
those numbers go up or should same sex
marriage,
um,
be be illegalized as those numbers go
up.
Um,
I think that reporting in turn
encourages people to reveal their inner
support.
So there is a trend and a cycle whereby
growing awareness and growing reporting
of this awareness leads to greater
acceptance.